- Well, this is actually really cool,
'cause you're executive producing
and starring in the fifth
Chronical Mysteries.
So what's it about for
people that don't know?
(audience claps)
- Okay, so my character,
this is a franchise.
Movies about, my character is a podcaster,
which just honestly comes
from my love of true crime,
you know, the whole genre.
And I really had to defend to my husband
why I spend so much time
listening to podcasts.
And I was like, "Oh, I'm
working on a project here."
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
So I developed a movie
series about my character is,
you know, follows these cold
cases, solves these crimes.
And this is our fifth movie.
It's been super fun.
You just put up a photo.
I actually got to, one
of the things I love
about being a producer is you
get to pull in your friends
and pull on favors from your friends.
And so Christian Alfonso, who
was on "Days of Our Lives"
for many years, a dear friend of mine,
happened to be filming in Vancouver.
And so I asked her to come play
the role for me in my movie.
And it just worked out.
- Wow.
- She's an amazing dear friend.
Like because of the lock
downs and the quarantine,
everything, I literally wept in her arms
when I saw her on set for
the first time (laughs).
And so it's just been
an amazing experience.
And I love like taking that idea
of these armchair detectives
that we listened to.
I think I heard that you
liked true crime too.
Is that right Kelly?
- Okay, here's the thing Allison.
I used to be obsessed
with it, and I'd watch it,
and then I found myself being terrified.
Like I was, I thought
watching it, I'd be like,
"Oh I have all these ideas to like,
if someone comes in my window,
then I'll do this.
(Allison laughs)
I gotta make sure to do this."
I thought I'd be, it'd be like, you know,
kind of empowering.
No, no, no, no, no.
I ended up like literally
sleeping like with one eye open.
I was just terrified
constantly all the time.
So I had to stop.
- So actually this case,
the helped to depth story, did
come from my like fascination
with a bunch of true crime cases.
You know, there's a lot about gurus
and some cult stuff that's happened lately
and like documentaries on Netflix
that I just like deep dive in.
It's a rabbit hole.
Netflix knows me so well, so.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)